at least seven people in China have been
killed after a hotel used as a
quarantine Center collapsed rescue
workers pulled 47 out of the 70 people
from under the rubble but more than a
dozen people are still trapped let's get
the very latest or I'll correspond
Katrina you who's following events the
hotel claps very late on Saturday night
and the rescue operation continues
Katrina that's right they've been
working overnight it happened about 7:30
local time they're still investigating
the causes of this collapse the landlord
of the hotel has been taken into the
police station for questioning the
central government has sent additional
forces to help with the emergency rescue
we're still trying to find out what
caused this exactly but we do know that
the hotel occupied the upper floors of
this building it was only two years old
so not a very old building but we do
know that the ground floor of this hotel
was being refurbished and that possibly
had something to do with the reason that
the structure gave way what else we know
is that this hotel was being used to
actually house people who were being
quarantined because of the coronavirus
about 50 or so people were being
quarantined and what's extremely
frustrating is that these people we've
just been told all tested negative for
the corona virus so they were being held
there to monitor their own health but
also to keep them away from the
community presumably to keep the
community safe but there is a lot of
frustration about this because it's an
example of these heavy-handed
restrictions being used to protect the
community from the corona virus but at
the same time having devastating
consequences for the people in this
hotel who are waiting to go through
their one to two a week quarantine
period of being there before they could
be released did keep your message of
course with the corona virus and what
are the Chinese authorities saying now
or today our numbers
that's right the Chinese Authority is
very much trying to divert attention
away from this tragedy and towards the
more positive news this weekend for the
first time we've had confirmed new cases
in China dropped below 100 and that's
very significant because just about two
weeks ago we were seeing thousands of
new cases every day and now we've got in
the last 24 hours 44 new cases and 27
deaths and the vast majority of these
new numbers are happening in Hubei
Province and according to this official
figures effectively the spread of
coronavirus outside who Bay Province has
has stopped because they say all these
these few cases that have come outside
abrir province were cases that were
actually imported from other countries
from actually imported from Italy and
imported from Iran so the government is
very much using this downward trend to
really push this positive propaganda
that look we put these heavy-handed
restrictions in place we locked down
millions we restricted the movement of
hundreds of millions and this these
numbers are proof that our methods are
working and indeed other countries have
a lesson or two to learn from us and of
course they're trying to bury very much
the criticism from earlier this year
that the reason this outbreak grew to
this scale was of course because of
incompetence or miss handling on the
part of local authorities in Hubei
Province for the update thanks very much
Katrina Katrina here our correspondent
in Beijing